oh I deleted it this is I feel like my
dad I've never used snapchat before no I
haven't I've heard about it though I'm a
little suspicious young people love
technology that older people don't know
how to use I know that the icon is a
ghost that does like I was sure that it
was just for nude pictures I could I
could send pictures of my junk and then
it's gonna be gone in 30 seconds or
something exactly there's a real appeal
to that I'll have to tell you then it
became clear that teams were just
sending funny images I'm ready to snap I
have to take an ugly selfie I don't want
it this is why I don't like snapchat
those are the rules it has to be an ugly
picture so I'm gonna reinvent a selfie
this gives me an excuse to do a duck
face it's really bad this is just me
bashing myself oh that's ugly I think I
hit the wrong thing dude I am so wasted
you should always do a dumb face and the
perfect option is date me date me yeah I
am so cutting-edge now where are my
filters whoo I can write that it's 3:20
I'm gonna go with hyper colorful my
stupid fat fingers feel like I'm doing
great is your mom on here can I send to
your mom oh damn it what's this
stopwatch in the bottom left that my
timer who would ever do one second that
we just rude well I guess if it's your
dick it's still sad that the pictures
gone in ten seconds
yeah I'm gonna take a video what my
video will be about oh wait a minute
what'll I do Wow
oh space everyone's good seems to be
like when did Alison become an astronaut
and now I'm gonna start talking and send
it to my buddy I'm gonna do my best
impression how from the film Titanic
I put the jewel in the coat I put the
coat on her yeah was that dumb this is
what my face would look like if my
nostrils were my eyes this is like a JJ
Abrams selfie this combines drawing and
selfies which are two things I'm
terrible at doing so this is like if I
was like hey do you guys want to come
watch me dance and do my own taxes at
the same time and the message I would
like to give people is don't waste your
time sweating the small stuff life is
too short
oh you can watch it for a limited amount
of time for 24 hours about to view my
best friend Gabby done stories okay now
she's at the MTV Movie Awards cool she
didn't invite me to that I have a lot to
say to Gabby
we had a version of this when I was in
middle school and it was just passing
notes if I was in high school this would
be a lot of fun I can get into it but I
also like to look at things I enjoy
permanence you know when people like
create art than the wave takes it away
on the sand like on beaches that you
know I mean they are not back smoking
crack so there's worse things to do then
snapchat it's more fun than I thought I
thought it was stupid but now I'm
enjoying it I just hope people don't get
carried away using it for sex pictures
all the time in my day we had the
polaroid for that but then you could
just throw it away
what's the terminology I got snapchatted
I'm snapping I'm snap snap in dis chat
yo